ونبدا بالتطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا اذ قال الجيش الاوكراني الى
القوات الروسيه نفذت خلال الساعات الماضيه
17 ضربه جويه واكثر من 60 هجوما صاروخياطه
الكهربائي والماء عن اجزاء الواسعه من غير
سنويكو لايف
قياده عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه عن تصاعدي
حده القصف المتبادل على طول ضفتين نهر
دنبر في خيرسون مشيره الى ان قوتها صدقت
هجمات روسيه في عدد من مناطق لوجان ومنع
التقدم القوات الروسيه باتجاه مدينه بخم
والتحديدا
اعلن حكم المقاطعه الموالي لروسيا عن مقتل
عشره اشخاص واصابه ثلاثه في قصف الاوكراني
بصواريخ هاي مارسي استهدفت مناطق في مدينه
ميلوتوبل
انا احد الصواريخ اصاب منتجعا سياحيا مما
ادى الى اندلاع النيراني فيه تحاول فرق
الاطفاء السيطره على الحريق واجلاء بعض
الاشخاص العالقين تحت الانقاذ